hey everyone happy holidays we are
getting hyped for the holiday season
with a gingerbread house this is Jenna
hello ready to decorate yeah this is
great
this is your do you did decorate me I
did Decker waiting to see that video
decorating is fun the building that is
not this is already pre-made this is a
small old house but I hope it's not
shattered did you pick this up at the
store or did you get everyone up at the
store I did a gingerbread house for it
actually knows a chocolate house for
well what's the last holiday Easter no
Thanksgiving
motto 31 October I did one for October
80 was broken you did one per October I
did so this is an unboxing of the
gingerbread house we've got my thing
there it is oh also got oh those are
probably candies I bet it's like some
fondant we've got some peppermint sticks
do you want mac and cheese candy canes
lutely not what's this okay more icing
oh here's the tip just one two tips
how many tips just two here's our help
and it's in perfect condition there is a
little cheat that you guys can do if you
ever do build gingerbread houses use hot
glue it just don't do it or don't do it
I think you're the tip on building
life-size gingerbread ovens don't do it
do pollute we do not do it do you think
this looks like our tradition where we
do it frequently we do I see frequent
enough I think they didn't on my channel
i'll actually remember oh I'm gonna roll
my sleeves up and do something while
getting hyped for the holidays I always
well so do you and say I do we both
travel home for the holidays and
traveling during the holidays is always
just wild because
everybody is traveling so the house has
lifted what's your favorite thing to do
during the holidays I feel like it's
nice because we've lots of time to do
things well time it's so funny that you
asked my favorite thing to do during the
holidays is listen to audible books I
actually know this because wouldn't
remember the holidays I always hear them
it's like the best thing because I
absolutely love audible so thank you
guys for sponsoring my videos because
honestly like this is something that I
truly absolutely love and there's
something new this holiday season for
audible for a limited time new members
of audible can get three months for 695
which is pretty incredible you guys can
go to autumn about la the /i justine or
text i just need to 500 500 they also
have these new things called audible
originals but i just downloaded my first
one i downloaded aliens they also have
audio fitness have you seen them no yes
it's actually super exciting so i
downloaded a few of those too because
usually when were traveling for the
holidays or traveling any time in
general trying to work out or make time
to do it it's usually a struggle but
look they have 5k trainings also have an
everyday meditation which goes through
20 days I got Michelle Obama's book
becoming I got for newbies Taylor's book
a sexy love story anyway if you guys
wanna check out audible audible.com
slash I just need or text I just need to
500 500 right here you should start the
other icing bag for best use place in a
little warm water now and this is gue
coming out of it
did you guys enjoy that if you eat this
you'll die your insides will look like
they're bleeding are all of our insides
technically we're gonna just decorate
the front which one is a friend
take your pick girl we don't have much I
say really need to plan this out really
bad at this you want me to do the icing
no you should
where do we just stick this on the
entrance of the house no you have to
have a door maybe it'll be a back door
you just let see it secret entrance
secret adjust this smells really good I
doing something bad
no I just know how much you love your
symmetry do I know you love your
symmetry you I like symmetry you've
talked about it so many times in videos
I like symmetry that doesn't go there
that would be not symmetric so here's
the thing I've gotten myself into a
pickle so I follow the pattern of the
lights or do I reverse I love how you
say symmetry symmetry I say like
cemetery symmetry but you say symmetry
symmetry symmetry symmetry symmetry some
cinnamon tree you should do no baby no I
don't know I'm going to what to read
around the Bottineau
there's been mud turn up the lights and
here baby been extra bright so Santa can
see you she'll be here all day
that looks good distant door using a
view yeah yeah here let me turn this for
you so you can get a better one
we need more color well it kind of
worked out but we're just going Janet
you're gonna get a tummyache stop eating
those right now cuz I don't want to have
to hear about it it's poison well it's
not sugar sugar is poison but it's
freaking delicious what do i do at the
green what they do with the green what
did they do with the green oh I like
what they've done what do they do I made
they've made windows that's nice baby
making oh it's gonna be a window I'm
just gonna add the 8 oh no I guess ya
fondant is it's uh it's hard to do
there's been a murder
there's been a murder what is that from
hey guys just said it okay
so jenna is a forensic scientist well I
should have been you should have been
but she's not that technically but you
don't have a degree in it so I'm gonna
put some blood splatter and I would like
for you to tell me how good has happened
there's been another boat you need
anything like eaten you know Oh shucks
this stupid chimney keeps falling down
alright so I think that our house is
done they have to start a flavor I'm not
just sugar really yeah okay so like
geez we'll see the front hold on I'm
making grass that's attorney how does a
green curve so just so we know not some
decorations that's a honor now it says
no no peeking in the present could you
turn that I really think that the bonus
decoration is really needed
what is it you ask a grass patch I was
on my phone I thought would make me a
video I have it a doormat oh my gosh
that looks good well guys here it is
this is our holiday festive actually
looks pretty good did you prepare - wow
I did some things since I look down from
my phone and looked up who's got all
[Music]
that's dangerous
when I thank you so much for watching if
you guys enjoyed this I would love to
hear from you guys what are some of your
holiday traditions and what do you guys
think we're doing for the holidays
anything nothing it's okay if you're not
a lot of difference are staying here
this year I know it's kind of crazy but
we'll be heading home visiting our
friends and our family great we're gonna
be in video three get ready do you guys
have any ideas of what you would like us
to do with free leave those also at the
confidence breeze our other sister if
you didn't know she's the middle sister
I'm the oldest and the baby then she's
the baby Bobby
well if you're old then you're my aunt
mrs. Claus I'll see you guys in the next
video
oh let Alexis fall in you had one job
that was your size
[Music]